hello and welcome to the second lecture
on the binomial theorem in this lecture
we will look at the binomial theorem and
some of the related results which can be
derived from binomial theorem first
recall the definition of NCR which is
the number of ways of choosing our
objects from n distinct objects and
which can be written as n factorial
divided by n minus R factorial times R
factorial so the binomial theorem
is given by our this result is X plus y
breaks to the N is NC 0 X to the N y to
the 0 plus NC 1 X to the N minus 1 y to
the 1 plus so on till NC n minus 1 X to
the 1 y to the 0 plus NC n X to the 0 Y
to the N where NC R is the number of
ways of ways of choosing R objects from
n distinct objects this can be more
succinctly written as the summation r
equal to 0 to n NC are X to the N minus
R Y to the R so the binomial theorem can
be taken to be an identity in X&Y the
binomial theorem is applicable for x and
y complex and and being a positive
integer
at this point I would like to mention
that generalizations of the binomial
theorem for the case when n is any real
number also exists so in the definition
in the expression of the binomial
theorem of we take X to the 0 to be
equal to 1 for all X which are complex
numbers so irrespective of the value of
x we define X to the 0 to be equal to 1
so you notice that there are n plus 1
terms in the binomial theorem and they
are not n terms but n plus 1 terms in
the binomial theorem and you notice that
there is sort of a pattern to the terms
in the binomial theorem and that is well
captured by the general term of the
binomial theorem in general the R plus 1
term in the expansion of X plus y to the
N can be written as NCR x to the n minus
r times y to the r so to give you an
example of the application of binomial
theorem or let's look at X plus y power
1 so from the binomial theorem we get
that this is nothing but 1 C 0 X power 1
Y power 0 plus 1 C 1 X power 0 Y power 1
which gives us X plus y which is what we
expect so we can also derive to the case
when we have X plus y whole square this
is nothing but 2 C 0 X power 2 Y power 0
plus 2 C 1 X power 1 Y power 1 plus 2 C
2
X power 0 y square and since 2 C 0 is 1
we have X square 2 C 1 is nothing but 2
we have 2 XY and 2 C 2 again this one so
via plus y Square and this is the
well-known result of X plus 5 the whole
square equals x squared plus 2xy plus y
square similarly you can derive that X
plus y the whole cube is X cubed plus 3x
squared y plus 3xy squared plus y cube
and you can derive this result from the
binomial expansion as well so one way in
which you can interpret the binomial
theorem is as follows so to derive X
plus y raise to the N is equal to this
expression just consider X plus y X to
the N is nothing but X plus y times X
plus y and so on times X plus y for a
total of n terms and the interpretation
of this expansion can be given as
follows so if you choose n X's then you
choose an X from each of these make each
of these parentheses here and so there
is only one way of choosing X's from
each of these parentheses so there is
only one way of choosing n XS + 0 Y's
and that gives you the coefficient of x
power n Y power 0 if you want to choose
n minus 1 X's from this expression then
you have to choose n minus 1 X's from
the end possible X's and you have to
choose one Y from the end possible Y's
and that can be done in n choose one
base and that gives you the coefficient
of x power n minus 1 times y power 1 and
so on
so in this way you can derive opti you
can provide a combinatorial
interpretation of the binomial expansion
so as I mentioned previously there are
generalizations for the binomial theorem
for the case when are this exponent n it
is not necessarily a positive integer
but when it can be any real number so
this is the general result of the
binomial theorem and you can derive
several related results by playing
around with the central result of the
binomial theorem for instance you could
replace Y by minus y in the theorem and
upon doing so you would get an
expression for X minus y next to the n
this is going to be NC 0 X to the n
minus y 2 0 plus NC 1 X to the n minus 1
minus y to the 1 and so on till NC n X
to the 0 minus y raised to the N and
this can be more simply written as
summation R equal to 0 to n minus 1 to
the R and see R X to the n minus R by 2
the R so this result is very similar to
the result we derived for the binomial
theorem the second result which we can
derive is by replacing Y by 1
in which case we can derive an expansion
4x plus 1 raised to the N as NC 0 X to
the N 1 to the 0 plus NC 1 X to the N
minus 1 1 to the 1 and so on NC n XO 0 1
to the N and this can be written as NC 0
X to the N plus NC 1 X to the N minus 1
and so on to NC n X to the 0 now to
arrive at a more simpler expression of
this result use the fact that NC R is NC
n minus R and you can derive this to be
equal to NC and X to the n plus NC n
minus 1 X to the N minus 1 and so on 2 n
3 0 X to the 0 and this last expression
can simply be written as summation R
equal to 0 to N and see our X to the R
and so this is the binomial expansion of
X plus 1 to the N similarly you can also
derive this result from the binomial
expansion you can derive an expansion
for X plus y to the M plus X minus y to
the N and if you apply the binomial
expansion for these two separate
expressions you will get 2 x + C 0 X to
the N y to the 0 plus NC 2 X to the N
minus 2 y squared and so on
the alternate terms will cancel out and
it will leave you with this result so
that's it for this lecture so hope you
had fun listening to the binomial
theorem and some of its related results
in the next lecture we will be looking
at some examples of the usage of the
binomial theorem and some possible
problems you will face in an exam
situation thank you